arnold schwarzenegger is the new host of
Celebrity Apprentice that's a real thing
that really happened and everybody is
today in the paper than in the blogs and
everything there everyone's wondering
what Arnold's catchphrase is going to be
okay
Trump of course had you for you so we're
wondering what is Arnold gonna do he's
probably not going to do that he needs
his own catchphrase maybe something from
one of his movies probably there's a lot
to base it on there yeah so we thought
what's at least examined some of the
possibilities let's do it right now
let's take a look there's awesome Avista
baby
there's your terminated you're
expendable you've been totally recalled
I command all you believe you're out of
the running man it's not a tool but you
own the tool that is well II have to
remove why don't you jingle all the way
to the unemployment line
I'll show you how the real damage is
alive for my movie called collateral
damage have you seen it cuz now you I
don't even I'm to see it and then I lose
because he's fired
two lies about you I'm not firing you
when I've never thought of eye renewal
you are not fired those are lies I'm
firing you did you know I turned down
the role of John located I odd if I'd
been in that film right now I'd be
saying he became I'll be back but you
won't
[Applause]
you